okay so this weekend a bunch of people
got banned on Twitch for streaming the
csgo Berlin major they were sir DMCA
takedown notices by the company
organizing the major which is starladder
i talked to one of those streamers Flom
about this whole situation I also looked
at starladders rules and regulations to
see what they actually say on this
subject and then we asked the question
where do we go from here
[Music]
well guys it has been a hot minute since
we've covered csgo directly on don't at
me now I'd like to tell you that I'm
excited to talk about the biggest
competition in my favorite eSports scene
but less than a week before I'm
scheduled to go cover the major in
Berlin we have some ugly business to
deal with a handful of streamers
including prominent csgo streamer and
personality Flom were banned from twitch
for broadcasting games from the Berlin
major now if you're new to csgo a major
capital m is a twice a year competition
that represents the pinnacle of that
eSport every major valve which is the
company that publishes csgo awards the
rights to produce organize and broadcast
the major to a different tournament
organizer and this time it's starladder
and it was starladder that served Flom
with the DMCA takedown notice DMCA
takedown notice obviously refers to the
Digital Millennium Copyright Act of 1998
it criminalizes the circumventing of
copyright law and it is supposed to be a
tool for originators of a certain work
to stop unauthorized reposting or
dissemination of that work basically all
you need to know is that if you're a
content creator on Twitch it is a really
big deal if you get one of these notices
now sorry from the beginning of this
whole controversy focusing it on Flom
who often participates in something
called the no majors Club now that is
like a talk-show podcast restream of the
major hosted by Richard Lewis and others
now Flom told me the day before he was
banned starladder reached out to the no
majors club and threatened them with
action richard comes back he's like ok
we came to an agreement all gonna be
fine they're gonna have their sponsors
into the go TV overlay which that's fine
like that makes perfect sense you're
putting your sponsors into the go TV
relay we're promoting them that's a
win-win for everybody that's not really
a big issue then the next day I cut a
direct message from Richard saying that
my channel had been banned and this was
like about 24 hours the past I'd say
from when they like contacted Richard
versus when I got the MCA and I didn't
know why I was banned I actually didn't
have a formal email even from twitch yet
of what had happened I'm fortunate
enough that I very good friends there
that I've just reached out to you
personally going hey what's going on and
I
this is accident which wasn't originally
I was upset with starladder but they
actually hadn't even seen the reasoning
get processed through their system yet
so they actually didn't know what
exactly i was the MC eight four they
just knew starladder had issued it and
that they had to take down my channel
now as Flom mentioned history was using
go t v-- which is an in client spectator
application that allows you to watch
games from POVs on a given server
it wasn't like anybody is watching the
stream that starladder is providing
we're not using their casters we're not
using any of their assets we're actually
watching a relay of a spectator client
that is built into the game of
counter-strike so starladder does not
own the game of counter-strike they get
the they get permission from valve to
stream the major now this is forms
first-ever ban on twitch he went public
with the info which is how most of us
heard about it and he was able to get in
touch with the guy who's in charge of
meteorites at starladder what starladder
told him is that essentially they own
the broadcast even on go TV they weren't
rude or unprofessional it was just this
is the way we've always done it this is
nothing new people have always
restreamed the major and they're telling
me now that they have exclusive rights
to it and that i actually should have
reached out to them to be able to stream
the major which that's never been done
before ever the majors have always been
to my understanding into i think the
whole community's understanding
something that we all get to watch
together we can turn on our streams as
long as we're not promoting our own
stuff we can just watch it with
everybody and there's no issue now
regarding the rights to the broadcast
starladders own rules and regulations do
state quote all broadcasting rights of
starladder major 2019 are owned by the
starladder limited this includes but is
not limited to video streams example POV
streams radio streams go TV replays
demos or TV broadcasts and quote Flom
was told nonetheless that his band would
be lifted and the next day starladder
put out a statement saying that all of
those DMCA takedown notices would be
rescinded i say all because obviously
Flom wasn't the only streamer who's
banned from twitch because of this tons
of other smaller channels were also
given the same treatment that Flom was
he even told me that starladder DMCA aid
their own official hungarian broadcast
channel which presumably was a mistake
now star letters tweet about rescinding
the DMCA takedown notices was
accompanied by a statement which read
quote the tournament license for the
csgo major grant starladder rights to
broadcast video content of the
tournament we use those rights to find
sponsorships and media contracts that
make the event possible it also notes
quote for the english language community
broadcast we will be happy to work with
community streamers if they would share
sponsorship obligations with us for more
information please contact us and quote
now given the language in that statement
and in starladders official rules and
regulations it seems entirely possible
that they could be well within their
rights to purge unauthorized broadcasts
of the major even via go TV now that
seems fine especially if they contact
the channel before trying to take them
down and explain that they need to as
starladder puts it share sponsorship
obligations with us however Flom says
that they told him that he needed to
contact them beforehand which seems
pretty unreasonable given that every
single major up until this point has
operated under a system where none of
this is necessary at this point it's all
just getting a little too murky yes so
that's why it gets really confusing is
the first time we'd ever seen that
wording is with ESL but they do not
choose to act on that that wording and
those those rights now this is the first
time that it's been acted on and the
thing is is if this is gonna change this
isn't something that you just add to a
rulebook somewhere and that someone has
to go deep into a website to go find
your rulebook and rules and stipulations
this is something that you should be
publicly stating from both sides
starladder should have mentioned hey
this is our rule set if you want to
stream it here's our terms and
conditions and here's how you stream the
major if you would like to be allowed to
and then from the other side valve if
they're selling exclusive rights to
people they need to come out and tell
everybody that they're doing that so
that way I don't get the MCA this should
be something that should be properly
conveyed and communicated at all times
there should be no disillusion - if
we're allowed to stream or not it should
be very plain text what we should and
shouldn't be allowed to stream for the
major the good news Flom channel is
indeed back and his DMCA takedown strike
is going to be apparently removed from
his twitch channel the bad news is
won't be streaming anymore of the Berlin
major until we get a more concrete
ruling on this very confusing issue
I can't risk another DMCA I am in
contact with starladder and working on
an agreement they did release a
statement today that was quite frankly
very vague and not definitive at
whatsoever that probably adds more
questions than settling them but
regardless I've been talking with them
and trying to come to some sort of
agreement it's kind of a stalemate so it
either I get permission from starladder
or valve comes out and says something
otherwise I will get the MCA if I try to
strain the matrix there's also a
potential downside for starladder in the
form of bad press no one in the
community really appreciated what
happened to Flom and others and plenty
of prominent voices took to Twitter to
voice their displeasure at the entire
situation now really interesting and
possibly relevant comparison here is
dota TV it's an in-game spectator client
exactly like go TV but obviously for
dota and in this case valve has come out
with a very clear ruling on how streams
using dotatv are to be conducted in a
blog post last year valve stated the
following quote the first issue we've
been seeing discussed is regarding DMCA
notices this one is very simple no one
besides valve is allowed to send DMCA
notices for games streamed off of dota
TV that aren't using the broadcaster's
unique content camera movements voice
etc the second issue is regarding who is
permitted to cast off of dota TV we've
designed the dota TV guidelines to be
flexible in order to allow for up and
coming casters or community figures like
bsj or bulldog that occasionally watch
tournament games on their channel to be
able to stream off of dota TV it is not
to allow commercial organizations like
BTS to compete with the primary stream
it'll be our judgment alone on who
violates this guideline and not any
other third parties and quote so as you
can see with dota TV it's valve coming
out and calling the shots
but with go TV at least with this most
recent major it seems like starladder so
far is in the driver's seat now we have
reached out to starladder for specific
comment beyond their statement on this
as of this recording they have not been
able to get back to me if and when they
do I will update you guys on their
perspective further but all this is to
say is that at this point what we really
need is a ruling from valve on go TV
just like they gave dota TV but until
that ruling is made public one way or
the other streamers like Flom are in a
gray area that they just can't cross now
to play devil's advocate here for a
second do streams like Flom Zoar the no
majors club take away valuable eyeballs
from the main starladder stream could
they potentially affect the Tio's bottom
line when it comes to hosting this major
well forum doesn't think so
if starladder wants to work side by side
with people i don't think there's any
downside to them as long as they have
their logos there we discuss it I've
actually worked with blast another
tournament organizer who has brought me
to events previously and I get to stream
there and I just provide them with my
numbers and they get to show that to
sponsors because we are providing extra
eyeballs to their sponsors and we're
adding additional value to their product
so I see no downside for them the only
downside is just by not communicating
with us and then DM saying we're taking
down or being really difficult to work
with and so here we are I ended my
interview with Flom by asking him at
this point what is the ideal resolution
for streamers like him I mean ten out of
ten would be valve coming out and
basically stating one way or the other
honestly in a perfect world I'd be
thrilled to have them and be like hey
watch it for everybody just like dota
you get to turn it on with your stream
and watch with Ustream I would also in a
perfect world they'll love to see
tournament organizers like starladder
reach out to people like me or richard
whoever to do more things together
because i'm not going away from
counter-strike I'm somebody that enjoys
counter-strike it's the game that I love
is the game that I want to stream a cm
that I want to play and I don't want to
not be able to do things with certain
tournament organizers because of bad
blood or Brent bridges I want to be able
to work with everybody do cool stuff
with them and promote the game and I
love that I've spent my entire life
playing and build it that way that
that's what I want I just want a clear
ruling and I just want an actual open
dialogue that continues moving forward
it seems kind of easy and cliche to say
but I think that's really just the best
way to go about it
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]